Ways to Decrease Our Water Consumption.
All over the world, water is becoming scarce.
Droughts have led to water restrictions in the cities...
...as well as in agriculture and manufacturing.
So, what are the best and most innovative ways...
...to decrease water consumption?
Here are some simple steps that people can take...
...to decrease their use of water:...
Only use the washing machine when it is full.
Turn off the faucet while brushing your teeth.
Keep your showers short.
A shower uses 10 to 20 liters of water a minute.
You don't sing in the shower anymore, do you?
It might not seem like a lot...
...but if everybody does those little things, it will add up,...
...don't you think?